she was the first one to arrive at her
first EU summit Theresa May the British
Prime Minister here to present the
latest update on the brexit process I'm
here with a very clear message the UK is
leaving the EU but we will continue to
play a full roll until we leave and will
be a strong and dependable partner after
we've left the British exit from the EU
but merely a side note at today's summit
pick on the agenda and on everybody's
mind the EU s responds to Russian
aggression in Syria it offered us via
its location also an alarm I hope that
we as the European Council will make
clear that what happens in Aleppo with
Russian support is completely inhumane
and that we need to work hard to reach a
ceasefire schnitz movie theater on
garbage animals and buses do stunts
hints of a coma tonight leaders will
discuss their tense relations with
Russia over dinner while the EU has
already imposed sanctions on Syrian
officials unanimity is lacking about
extending the measures to Russia the EU
should keep all options open including
sanctions if the crimes continue and
finally there's the issue of illegal
migration in particular Italy's Matteo
Renzi wants to see progress his country
is now on the main migration route to
Europe EU member states are now
discussing deals with countries of
origin such as Molly Ethiopia and Niger
to limit the streams of migrants from
Africa leaders in Brussels are once
again stuck in crisis talks